elon musk recently spent 3 billion or so
to buy just over 9
of equity in twitter and the world went
absolutely crazy elon musk the world's
richest man jumping onto one of the most
popular social media platforms in the
world he's going to shake things up
improve their product and maybe even
help protect free speech sounds awesome
right well elon didn't waste any time
and he immediately got to work tweeting
trying to figure out what do users want
first here's an example of him trying to
suggest that dogecoin could be added as
a payment method for premium twitter
blue subscriptions that sounds
absolutely insane but elon's gonna elon
then elon also went ahead and ran a poll
to his millions and millions of
followers that suggested that maybe we
should convert twitter's san francisco
headquarters to a homeless shelter since
no one shows up anyways pretty damn
funny and so elon musk was doing exactly
what people expected them to shaking
things up throwing a couple of jokes in
there and trying to actually maybe
create shareholder value well as part of
the deal twitter they could have run
away from this they could have fought it
or they could have leaned in to elon
musk buying nine percent of the business
and they initially tried to lean into it
they offered elon a board seat and it
looked like he was gonna go ahead and
join twitter's board of directors but in
a twist of fate last night all of a
sudden the twitter ceo went ahead and
posted a tweet where he said elon's not
joining the board we don't have that
much information but elon musk not
joining the board of directors is a
twist that no one saw coming so now is
elon trolling is he actually going to
position himself for some sort of
activist takeover or is elon just busy
running tesla and spacex and neurolink
and a million other companies that he's
got going on nobody actually knows what
i found interesting about this letter
from the twitter ceo two employees was
that he explicitly said there's gonna be
a lot of distractions ahead but our
goals and priorities remain unchanged if
you're sitting here as a twitter
shareholder you got to be disappointed
the world's richest man
and one of the greatest entrepreneurs of
our lifetime he was going to join your
board of directors seemed like he had a
lot of momentum going now he's not going
to do that i don't know whether you
should fear this or not but something
tells me we're gonna find out in the
next couple of days now if we go ahead
and we look at a breakdown of this idea
around the activist shareholder elon
musk not taking a board seat could be
bullish for free speech coming back the
board seat was a proposed tactic by
twitter's current execs and board to
curb his influence he would have only
been allowed to buy up to 14.9
but now if elon musk wants to pursue a
hostile takeover he's going to be able
to do that if we take a look at
twitter's share price over the last
couple of years it ain't pretty you can
see that twitter started out in 2014
trading above 60 dollars it pretty much
went down only until 2017 2018 it did
eventually recover back in 2020 through
2021 but then it went flying down again
see that big dip and then the recovery
at the far right of this graph that's
elon musk announcing that he had bought
nine percent of the business and was
gonna be joining the board of directors
i have no clue what elon's gonna do but
of course all the meme accounts across
the internet they're loving this elon
did he decide that he didn't want to
join the board because of some stupid
rules or some ability for them to then
censor him i have no clue but what i do
know is that the world's richest man has
a lot of money and he seems to really
care about free speech and twitter seems
to not be doing things the way he
believes they should be done and so if
elon musk becomes a true activist
investor and he takes a run at a hostile
takeover of twitter it will be
absolutely fascinating to watch i
wouldn't bet against elon musk i
wouldn't bet against a man who
understands how to create memes on the
internet i wouldn't bet against somebody
who has billions and billions of dollars
that he can throw around without any
sort of care on whether he makes money
or loses money elon musk and twitter is
going to be one of the most interesting
things to watch in the coming weeks hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time